hello my avatars name is archivist 11
and I ask me patrons question from the
neil armstrong library and archives at
NASA Cola and second month
inflation in the very early universe is
the dominant paradigm results from wmf
have shown that there are primordial
power fluctuations that support the
inflation era not what is the prospect
for plank measurements of CMV to truly
test the inflation paradigm that is
either potentially to provide a smoking
gun for it or to show that there are
serious problems thank you ok avatar
Ellen you're asking a pretty interesting
technical question the story of the
expanding universe and now has as a
basis the idea of inflation a idea that
in the first sub microseconds of the
universe there was an expansion that was
so rapid that the initial piece of the
universe which was maybe only 10
centimetres across expanded so rapidly
that light could not even keep up with
the expanding universe is a rather
tricky concept it seems to be true in
the sense that it matches the data that
we have but is pretty hard to test
nevertheless there is a prediction which
can be tested by studying the small
spots on the map of the cosmic heat
radiation and it's already been tested
pretty well by the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe the w map mission and
they say yes it matches the theoretical
prediction and the number that would be
maybe exactly one in an in basic theory
is actually 0 point nine seven and that
this number is what's predicted by some
versions of inflation now point nine
seven is pretty close to one and so the
difference isn't very large so it's
pretty important to go test it and
measure it again so the plonk mission
which does a similar job to what W map
does but hopefully even better will give
us a better test and will either confirm
or dispute the claim from the w map
results that the inflation really does
explain what the pattern of spots is on
the sky so we hope for the best thank
you